[Música]
un abrazo de respaldo el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden visitó este
lunes por sorpresa kiev y se reunió con
su homólogo bolodimir selenski a cuatro
días de que se cumplió el primer
aniversario del inicio de la invasión
rusa a Ucrania fueron más de 5 horas de
visita con el anuncio de un nuevo
paquete de 500 millones de dólares de
ayuda
Turquía sufre el azote de otros dos
terremotos justo cuando se cumplen dos
semanas de los seísmos que sacudieron el
sur del país y el norte de Siria que han
dejado un saldo parcial de más de 47 mil
muertos los terremotos de este lunes se
reportan al menos tres muertos y más de
200 heridos en suelo Turco
aumenta a 40 la cifras de muertos por
los deslaves en el estado de Sao Paulo
en Brasil hay decenas de desaparecidos
mientras cientos de rescatistas buscan
por supervivientes en una tragedia que
enluta las celebraciones del carnaval
momento de actualizar las noticias aquí
en la pantalla de France 24 Gracias por
continuar con nosotros Mi nombre es Juan
pupiales comenzamos esta emisión
hablando de lo más reciente de la guerra
en Ucrania la noticia del día está con
la visita Sorpresa del presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden a Ucrania el
mandatario norteamericano ya partió de
kiev y arribó en las últimas horas
Apolonia en donde se espera que entregue
un discurso desde Varsovia Este martes
esos interpreta como un contrapeso a una
locución que dará el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin en el marco del estado de
la unión en total fueron más de cinco
horas de las que estuvo biden en el
suelo ucraniano a cuatro días del primer
aniversario de la invasión rusa veamos
el informe de Andrés triviño
las alarmas antiaéreas sonaron en kiev y
en todo Ucrania Pero esta vez no para
alertar sobre un nuevo ataque ruso sino
para anunciar la sorpresiva visita del
presidente de estadounidense Joe biden
la primera vez que pisa territorio
ucraniano desde el inicio de la guerra
el mandatario reafirmó su compromiso con
este país y anunció una nueva asistencia
militar por 500 millones de dólares
justo hoy es anuncio incluye municiones
de artillería paraimars y obuses más
misiles sistemas blindados y radares de
vigilancia aérea que protegerán al
pueblo ucraniano de los bombardeos
aéreos
es el tiempo que estaremos con usted
señor presidente es el tiempo que sea
necesario
los detalles del nuevo paquete de ayuda
serán especificados el martes pero vayan
adelantó quien pondrá nuevas sanciones a
Rusia con sus tradicionales gafas de
aviador el líder de la Casa Blanca se
paseó por las calles de la capital
ucraniana y junto a selenski visitó la
catedral para rendir homenaje a los
soldados ucranianos caídos selensky
resaltó la importancia simbólica que
implica la presencia de vaiden en la
zona de conflicto además de calificarla
como una visita histórica Estados Unidos
aseguró que informó a Rusia sobre la
presencia de vaiden en Ucrania horas
antes de su llegada podemos y debemos
hacer de este 2023 el año de la Victoria
quiero enfatizar que esta guerra rusa
criminal y no provocada contra Ucrania
toda Europa y el mundo democrático debe
terminar con la limpieza de toda la
Tierra ucraniana de la ocupación rusa y
firmes garantías de seguridad a largo
plazo tanto para nuestro país como para
toda Europa y todo el mundo el
presidente estadounidense tiene previsto
realizar una visita oficial a Polonia
donde se reunirá con líderes de la otan
para analizar la situación y el futuro
de la guerra
entre tanto la Unión Europea anunció que
prepara una nueva serie de sanciones
contra Rusia el jefe de la política
exterior del bloque Joseph aseguró que
para esta semana estaría aprobado el que
sería el décimo paquete contra el
kremlin y que tendría por objetivo
medidas contra bancos así como la
importación exportación de algunos
productos rusos voy a on the way of
provening it estamos en camino de
aprobarlo y creo que se aprobarán las
próximas horas o en los próximos días
antes en cualquier caso un juego
el décimo paquete de sanciones se
aprobará por procedimiento escrito antes
del 24 de febrero los obstáculos que aún
subsisten serán superados Este es el
compromiso de nuestros ministros
vamos a Turquía y Siria porque dos
terremotos se hicieron sentir en estas
naciones justo cuando se cumplen dos
semanas desde el primer seísmo que
sacudió esta zona y deja llama de 47 mil
muertos en ambos territorios el
movimiento telúrico de este lunes afectó
sobre toda la provincia turca de hatay
una de las más devastadas por los
seísmos del 6 de febrero las autoridades
del país se reportan al menos tres
muertos y más de 200 heridos en Siria
Los cascos blancos registran más de 130
heridos la mayoría de ellos fuera de
gravedad por la caída de escombros
escuchemos ahora cómo se vieron estos
momentos de pánico en Turquía
fue realmente aterrador nunca había
experimentado un terremoto tan fuerte
vine a hathai como voluntaria del
partido de los trabajadores para ayudar
a las víctimas del terremoto
[Música]
la gente entró en pánico fue un
terremoto muy fuerte había edificios
cerca de las carpas donde estábamos
entonces la gente quedó aislada de sus
familias
en noticias de América Latina las
autoridades del estado de Sao Paulo en
Brasil reportan al menos 40 muertos y
más de 300 damnificados tras un fin de
semana de lluvias récord el gobierno
Estatal decretó la calamidad pública y
anunció la liberación de 1,3 millones de
dólares de ayuda para las tareas de
rescate el presidente Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva visitó la región y prometió
paliar los daños
Caos y destrucción tras una fuerte
jornada de lluvias récord que afectó el
norte del estado de Sao Paulo en Brasil
en especial en la ciudad de Sao
Sebastián durante el fin de semana de
carnaval provocando inundaciones y
deslizamientos de tierra el gobierno de
Sao Paulo decretó el estado de calamidad
pública por 180 días en las cinco
ciudades más afectadas y el presidente
Lula da Silva prometió una acción o
coordinada
puedo garantizar que mis ministros y el
gobernador están dispuestos a dialogar
para que podamos trabajar conjuntamente
para reparar de manera efectiva los
daños que la lluvia ha ocasionado aquí
en Sao Sebastián
las lluvias acumularon unos 600
milímetros superando el nivel que se
esperaba para todo el mes de febrero en
medio del carnaval además de los cientos
de personas que se vieron obligadas a
evacuar sus hogares muchos viajeros que
decidieron pasar sus vacaciones en la
región también tuvieron que evacuar
desastre por el que el gobierno como
local haya anunciado el desembolso de
alrededor de un millón y medio de
dólares para las tareas de rescate y
reconstrucción
ayer no pudimos sacar nuestro auto Así
que está dañado y casi perdemos otras
cosas de dentro de casa
la situación está crítica sólo tenemos
una salida para ir hacia Sao Paulo está
todo inundado
estamos medio aislados aquí con ráfagas
de viento que marcaron hasta 55
kilómetros por hora el Instituto
Nacional de meteorología reportó que las
lluvias continuaran en la zona costera
del estado en los próximos días Lo que
podría agravar la situación
precisamente esa tragedia en Sao Paulo
enluta las tradicionales celebraciones
del carnaval en varias partes de Brasil
fuera de este país también otras
naciones festejan al ritmo de la música
y los disfraces Y en este año ya sin
ninguna restricción por el covid 19
desde arriba hasta Barranquilla pasando
por oruro cada pueblo celebra de una
manera distinta pero comparten la
memoria a la diversidad que dio origen a
las culturas de las Naciones
latinoamericanas Max Pérez Gallardo nos
lleva por este recorrido
la región del color febrero mes de
carnavales para América Latina celebra
la diversidad que nutre a los pueblos
este año las complejidades políticas de
la región también se asoman en la fiesta
y muchos artistas están aprovechando el
espacio de los carnavales para
expresarse políticamente en Brasil las
tensiones originadas por el proceso
electoral que el país vivió
recientemente han salido a flote en esta
edición
es una doble alegría porque somos libres
de nuevo con toda la libertad de
expresión y peleando por nuestros
derechos para que todos seamos iguales
no hay diferencias entre colores de piel
creo que el carnaval va a ser una
celebración de esta conquista
democrática el carnaval es felicidad
Colombia es el hogar de otro festival
icónico de la región el carnaval de
Barranquilla representa un homenaje a la
identidad del país es una mezcla de
tradiciones prehispánicas y de la
colonia que resulta en una celebración
al mestizaje latinoamericano el carnaval
del Barranquilla la fiesta cultural más
importante por su diversidad por la
inclusión por la variedad producto de la
combinación de triernias que se da en
tierras bolivianas el festival de oruro
es sinónimo de remembranza a los
orígenes del país considerado como
patrimonio oral e intangible de la
humanidad por la UNESCO el festival
despliega una mezcla entre dioses
andinos e iconografía cristiana río
oruro Barranquilla tres palabras
sinónimo de una explosión de colorido
mezcla de razas y de patrimonio cultural
que cada año atraen decenas de miles de
turistas
con mucho color despedimos esta emisión
informativa aquí en la pantalla de
France 24 la invitación es para que
ustedes continúen aquí y también en
nuestro sitio web France 24.com
[Música]